MODERATOR: And now you should be able to start reading the tasks and to move the mouse around around the screen.
P3: So what you see on your screen or two panels with labels.
P3: Labels left panel and main panel okay read the text within home.
P3: out loud.
P3: An explorer as a source of your choosing by right clicking and opening a new tab once you feel you understand where the data comes from please click the button open map.
P3: To visualize the density of data points within the locations of interest he will be done when you mentioned a few of the locations of interest that have data points available okay so.
P3: To see dashboards hide the complex seeds in making clinical rare disease data with environmental observations using knowledge graph the desired outcome is to support health data researches.
P3: identify appropriate environmental variables, to enable that hypothesis exploration and researching rare diseases Okay, how to use the dashboard select and submit the query inputs on the left.
P3: explore the resulting linked environmental data here after clicking submit export the data for your needs a text file named user query history is automatically saved in the.
P3: Local folder with the history of your query input selections you will be able to use this file to get the data directly through an API in the future.
P3: Data environmental observations have been gathered from weather pollution and aerosol data right click and open in a new tab data points density check the button and hover over the region to get the number of data points okay so rare disease uncut event of interest.
MODERATOR: So Would you mind for us finishing task one.
P3: task one oh right sorry.
P3: Oh right, yes, sir.
P3: So, whether new.
P3: Okay, so that comes from that Aaron.
yep.
P3: Is this the actual sources that you plan to use or is this just a domain.
P3: Oh, you can't tell me okay air quality that I EPA interesting I actually always wondered whether the air indexes are accurate and my dad was like Jim you know you want your environment till research I think thing I you smoke, it is like yeah I know my thought already.
P3: And then error cell from error net so interesting not heard of that one nothing.
P3: OK back to the dash and then.
P3: When you understand.
P3: click open map.
P3: Okay.
P3: Well, I get where they're coming from to open them up oh and look at the knife map.
P3: So now, I want to get your arm and so.
MODERATOR: I think that's because of the live chat.
MODERATOR: Let me, let me fix it.
MODERATOR: Now you can you can go again.
P3: So.
P3: that's always.
P3: Changing I don't see my mouse doesn't seem to be interacting with it.
MODERATOR: Okay, maybe you need to click again some window.
Okay.
P3: So go away population one.
P3: Whether to data density points three So what does that mean.
P3: The populations here whether their.
P3: Population tree population tree whether they're.
P3: So what does this mean the number of ideas that you have with the number of.
MODERATOR: Make sure you read the names correctly Jim.
P3: county pollution weather and data density data points density.
P3: So does that mean there are four stations in Tipperary, that are contributing to the data.
P3: Oh, you can't tell me right.
P3: density of days is like within the location of.
P3: Three people in Galway that have.
P3: Data on pollution and whether or is it put the three.
P3: sources of pollution and weather data in going.
MODERATOR: It will be the second.
P3: Okay well that's not very clear, so I would just make up.
Your.
P3: Okay, am I doing with exercise one.
P3: She know what this is like it's like being in and he knows, have you done the gains for why do you have to like figure out the puzzle before you can be.
P3: Here, like yeah I know i'm serving you, but I can't tell you anything.
MODERATOR: Exactly.
P3: Okay right.
P3: i'm not a shark today i'm pretty tired.
P3: query using the input.
P3: options available in the query top.
P3: My connection is unstable it tells me.
P3: i'm trying to get there, we are okay so i'm in the query top.
P3: While you are selecting the query options, please explain the specific choices that you're making as you make choices new ones will be available, once you read the end, please click submit.
P3: which will be only which will only be available if valid points have been selected, you will be done when a new top named Q one is displayed in the main panel at the dashboard okay so i'm interested in i'm Kurt yes event of interest let's go with definite location.
P3: He.
P3: invented interest dates.
P3: Okay, so these are all the date.
P3: In various counties, that would be will be have a document flair.
P3: So let's go with Dublin because there's going to be more there.
P3: And it's obviously in Ireland.
P3: Do you really have to click on and like it.
MODERATOR: is for the whole for the whole country, so all right.
P3: All right, Okay, well, I would maybe have brackets click here, if you want the whole country.
P3: But, in general, what kind of probably want the whole country you know, because you own the dope lemon court cup like high density of cases.
P3: still confused by this data points density thing it looks to me like Cork in Dublin are.
P3: have more data density points in the rest of the country, but I don't imagine they have more weather or pollution stations, I think it's just that there's more occupations in those counties.
MODERATOR: it's a stations.
P3: Really, so they have more stations that is interesting, I wonder why that is anyway let's look from.
P3: The first of August.
P3: The maximum seem to be cooperating.
P3: Okay let's go with the 15th of August, then, to the.
P3: right one, maybe.
P3: Three months.
P3: let's do that.
P3: And I want both whether i'm creation and I want it in.
P3: So.
P3: i'm looking for the data that relates to definite flares.
P3: Between these dates for both whether i'm pollution.
P3: I mean you given me the let's say monthly.
P3: data for each variable per ID.
P3: For that month or the third presumably the date refers to the date that they had a definite flare, so I would want like a month.
P3: or two months or three months or four months or five months or six months.
P3: of data of each variable prior to that flatter.
P3: And I want to be able to aggregate there by daily average monthly up probably monthly average.
P3: and
P3: be able to compare the monthly average let's say in the month leading up to that date, compared to the three months prior to that date So what is this telling me.
MODERATOR: Just straight to move forward.
Okay.
P3: So let's go with monthly, although I don't know what month are you giving me I want the mean usually but I, like the fact that there's a Min and Max.
P3: Okay.
P3: So.
P3: I still don't really know what it's given me but anyway we'll see what comes up with.
P3: I like where you're going with it there.
P3: This is what I would plan to do in fact I was thinking of how to aggregate this data from the raw data dump that out, someone give me.
P3: But also, what I want is.
P3: So I want to look at let's say the monthly averages prior to be the basket like flares well i'd also want to be able to pull a different date that they were in remission.
P3: Okay, all the data.
Around.
P3: am I talking too much.
MODERATOR: No that's perfect like the more the better for me to just do.
P3: Like, for example, and it's quite difficult for you to pick out a random date of permission so i've managed to do a code that does that so i'd want to be able to input dates that I want the data prior to.
P3: yeah and i'd want to be able to let say uplift a csv file to say for these ideas and these dates get me the data prior to that.
P3: OK OK so here anyway, I have month eight 910 in 2020 and a half the average.
P3: Rain temperature.
P3: We.
P3: Can we click on it wet cold air temperature.
P3: Oh, that doesn't the other way around.
P3: EP vapor pressure.
MODERATOR: Do you want, do you want to go pocket fitting the task.
P3: Oh right, I was on task number two.
P3: Oh, and this is it explore the query one top.
P3: query.
P3: No, I didn't see q1 anywhere but that might because of my.
P3: My oh there we go.
P3: So the full name of the variables, with the units appear when hovering over the headings table yeah for further information, please refresh the data sources links in the home tab which I had a look at the toggle call us button allows to select allows you to select the columns of interest.
P3: And the export button to download the data as a csv file to your computer only the visible columns will be downloaded so I presume this circle, with the line triggers are.
P3: likely to delete that column would that be right.
P3: These circles that I was clicking I obviously with deleting those columns.
P3: it's not right.
P3: So I would have someone like notification of what they bought means I mean from clicking it looks like it means delete.
P3: But that's not a parent until i've deleted it.
P3: And neither toggle.
P3: Okay, and so you can click here as well, right well let's say I want brain temperature.
P3: was very fast moving.
P3: So, like a preview.
P3: semi.
P3: Maybe i'll do that for free.
P3: So this is the ability now.
P3: I see like might yeah I don't mind PM to five, even though that but, like 25.
P3: nights to that side Oh, we have suffered outside that's exciting, so you know the UK people find that soft outside of maybe suggestive interior design concept.
P3: You need that right.
P3: and carbon monoxide okay anyway i'm cutting off the point in order to understand the table, there are two buttons that help you interpret data table click both buttons on top.
P3: Open query input summary.
P3: So that tells me what query I made right.
P3: and open color table description.
P3: to your colors data table background if data is normally distributed know five Central be between the aca and then the value is greater than two are high and okay great What about if they're not normally distributed which i'm sure, a lot of the data.
P3: Especially if you're looking at clinical data, a lot of it will be not normally distributed.
P3: then read the text and the data okay did that and.
P3: Talk through the interpretation of the variables and the cell background colors.
P3: off the table, you can select the columns that you want to display with the toggle columns okay know that you can scroll vertically and horizontally, which i've been doing and using the page arrows on the bottom right hand corner okay.
P3: You scroll down anymore.
MODERATOR: that's that's for me.
Right.
P3: and
P3: Does it scroll down more for my at the bottom of the page.
MODERATOR: it's fine.
Okay.
P3: i'm trying to go.
P3: i'm gonna go across here.
P3: me.
P3: Okay, so I can just see white background, so I presume that means everything's within its normal distribution the 95% confidence interval.
P3: And then.
P3: I still i'm not sure so let's take rain in August 20 the average.
P3: monthly so with that the month of August was Point two.
P3: And that relates to Dublin.
P3: So all the ideas that have lyrics.
P3: That doesn't make sense, then, because.
P3: It doesn't match up with the dates of the.
P3: Air like what I want is for each ID.
P3: player date I want aggregated data for every month prior to that flare for like six or 12 months.
P3: Whereas this i'm getting.
P3: A random date range that I put in there that doesn't actually equate to the flare dates at all is that right.
MODERATOR: yeah I need to prove it in the next one.
P3: Okay um no.
P3: I think, especially at this table so explore the other tabs beside the jury should have all three are interactive with features for different purposes.
P3: Please use those features for each pot, while mentioning the usefulness of each one in understanding the environmental data you'll be done when you have explored through the interactive features for each Okay, so that first time series.
P3: So time series plot visual story along time visual story a long time that sounds odd.
P3: But I know what you mean the visualization of interactive plot zoo harbor pan and download legend click the variable to D select and Double Click to select ranger slider click and drag to select the period of interest on the bottom plot.
P3: The best runs from August to November ish.
P3: And the value is 02 minus one or plus one so it's I preview standardized data.
P3: What kind of foundation standardization, is it doing.
P3: I know there's various types, because I looked at these kind of these called parallel plots and in our before, and they were all doing very standard ization so i'd like to know what so then let's say we want to take out a few so i'm taking a temperature no let's give them the temperature.
P3: doesn't seem to be a Double Click it seems we have click or not correct so.
P3: leave him rain and temperature to cope what be.
P3: Okay, this is your shoulder to see like visually is there a relationship between things.
P3: But again you're comparing like.
P3: A time and relax versus the time and not relapse and while here, you might be able to look at all the patients together and see like his brain full way down here for all the patients.
P3: But if we're looking to compare a patient to themselves, you don't want a plot of their relapse versus a plot of their permission, you know just by by side, but also, you need to standardize.
P3: The.
Plus.
P3: like this.
P3: confused that we're looking at this doesn't relate to any patient this stuff related to a period of time, so like where is the flare on this plot, you know it should really be.
P3: flare is here.
P3: and
P3: Then, so we know where the floor is tuner.
P3: And then.
P3: If we're trying to look at a load of people together, then.
P3: Like How would you visualize because at the minute we're looking in theory at just one patients data right because it's people in Dublin, for example.
P3: So, in order to see a consistent POPs in and multiple people over time.
P3: You almost need to parallel plot all the people who are having a flare and have flare at time zero, and then the average of.
MODERATOR: All the variables yep yep.
P3: I would think.
yep.
P3: um, but it is interesting to see how things change but it's how they changed in relation to the event so.
P3: Here you've got a nice idea of how things are going, but not how they relate anyway box plot.
P3: The box bones the into courses range divided by the media and.
P3: Two piece style whiskers they're called extended to a maximum of 1.5 times the into a quarter mile range beyond the box.
P3: I thought that the whiskers where the maximum the men, and this was the medium and then this.
P3: would sit back and 25.
P3: Okay, the visualization is interactive plops through hover COM and download so we're looking at the variable here and the value again standardize, so this is just showing us the distribution of each variable is that right.
P3: um.
P3: Which.
P3: i'm not sure if that useful to have that standardized because.
P3: Like would you not really want to see what the actual absolute values are.
MODERATOR: You seeing the following tasks.
Okay.
P3: I mean what does this tell me that there is.
P3: Like I don't know what the entire quarter ranges for each variable so the absolute Barry ation might be quite small or it might be quite big so i'm not really sure what the benefit of his club is.
So.
P3: i'm hovering over giving me.
P3: A median men, you see your point in the Min and Max here is that not true.
P3: But you told me the whiskers.
P3: relate to something else.
MODERATOR: will come this comes in later.
P3: Okay, and.
P3: I like the way Oh, but it's still standardized.
P3: Okay i'd be interested to know what i'm supposed to get out of the plot anyway we'll move on to polar plot.
P3: This scatter polar plots complex variable wind dependencies the radius length indicates the wind speed on the direction of the wind direction and the degrees their wins and their degrees off winder actually.
P3: The visualization is interactive okay.
P3: select.
P3: Left look at the rain.
P3: and
P3: Wind the wind direction rain.
P3: rain.
P3: Okay So what does it mean.
P3: The radius lead indicates the wind speed Okay, so I can see the wind speed on the direction, but what does this relate to when does this.
P3: relate to who does it relate to.
P3: And what relevance is the rain.
P3: Again i'm not sure how this person on devices.
P3: I might be wrong.
MODERATOR: For you.
P3: Might finish now again I don't see any different colors so this almost be 95%.
P3: there's something outside of be.
P3: Oh, maybe that's just the data table.
P3: I think I should move on to Question five is that right.
P3: yep create two new queries so that's over here after you have submitted them following the same instructions and step two, you will see q2 q3 of new panels Now you can compare them in the comparative top read the text in this top.
P3: number of groups, you wish to Mike and click on click to generate groups and you input or group will appear on to me.
P3: Okay i'm going to start with long.
P3: So can I refresh it no, I have to click through it okay so that's the same let's stay with jack but let's go to.
P3: All.
P3: go away we'll go.
MODERATOR: Island selected again.
P3: Okay.
P3: i'll try and.
P3: go from the second.
P3: To.
P3: And let's just go with less time and I want.
P3: parent be enough telling me pollution varies quite a lot over the day across season so it's better to go abroad or average he was saying so let's go with monthly.
P3: But again i'm picking a date range that doesn't relate to people at all so i'm not sure how those two up and i'm going to submit.
P3: Okay, so there's actually not much data here.
P3: So delete the ones that.
P3: We have no data for And why is that.
P3: Something like this, so we only have ozone to go away.
P3: And then I need to do it again so let's go for Cork, this time.
P3: and
P3: Okay, more data here.
P3: I can't scroll across lots of all the data we have okay so then i'm going to comparative query data previously submitted in the session can be compared by specific variable.
P3: He can combine these queries into groups with the multiple selection inputs to potentially increase the signal to noise ratio decide the number of groups that we wish to compare.
P3: select which queries he wants to.
P3: explore each environment variable with different plots queries are grouped by confusion, the mean per unit of time in time series plot by come fascinating the valleys in the box.
P3: Okay, all right.
P3: But let's go back to go.
P3: to generate groups.
P3: group one.
P3: Okay, so you can compare different places.
P3: So what would actually make more sense if you will compare time points.
P3: So, like definite versus permission.
P3: For the individuals or for.
P3: A standardized.
P3: variable for each individual indefinite versus permission, maybe.
P3: range of queries.
P3: click.
P3: Oh wait for the groups in there, the queries.
P3: read the text that's left the number of groups three then click on generate groups which we did.
P3: A range of queries in the groups and click on click plot.
P3: Their sub tubs will have appeared with three different visualizations pays mentioned and usefulness.
P3: or not come with the rain.
P3: callback error update on.
MODERATOR: That that's let's.
MODERATOR: keep going.
P3: So I have no plot there Oh, because I compare it pollution, so I need.
P3: Some latent variable and there was only one there, and one of them.
P3: Okay i'm looking in there either.
P3: box.
P3: temperature.
P3: Because it's just the group.
P3: So let's go with my age.
P3: But I thought there was another.
P3: variation variable it's why we haven't seen a great.
P3: i'm pretty sure i'm for examples and all of them.
P3: So it was Dublin Galway Cork.
P3: So ozone is higher in Galway in the period of automatic thing.
P3: So what would be more useful is if this variable higher or lower in different disease activity states.
P3: Actually, that will be very useful okay.
P3: Because in essence that's what we're trying to see.
P3: cuz because it's not we don't have enough people in each county to compare let's face the onset of anchor in Galway vs core because that heavily dependent on.
P3: The fact that we're all based in Dublin so more people get diagnosed up here and where this kind of thing will be useful, is an equinox kind of thing where you're comparing on code yes versus a control.
P3: Whereas we have to compare between the individual because we have only anka compared to nothing, so we have to compare relapse and remission.
P3: Okay, so I see where you go with the box and then the distance.
P3: Yes, try ozone again seeing that we know exists.
P3: Right.
P3: me.
P3: Some labels on this graph will be.
P3: different from what.
P3: So with these coordinates.
P3: No.
P3: absolutely no idea what this ground.
P3: And the time series.
P3: is still seem to want to work for me doesn't.
MODERATOR: Think it's it broke.
Oh.
P3: So I move on.
MODERATOR: Yes, please.
Okay.
P3: choose one of the queries to export, so we will export very one.
P3: I do, like the idea of being able to compare them so but, as I say, I think it's primarily comparing within so query one go to that tab and click export.
P3: Export there we are okay.
MODERATOR: Let me close it otherwise you don't have to worry to my computer okay.
P3: Finally, civic download on the Left panel and click download.
P3: With all.
P3: So, presumably the data is stored in my local folder or something.
MODERATOR: It now it's in mind.
P3: Okay, and finally, could you summarize verbally your overall experience in completing these tasks, then please proceed to complete the questionnaire, well, I thought the tasks are very easy to understand.
P3: The dashboard is relatively easy to go than the things that I mentioned already um.
P3: Well, as I said, the outcome is where I would adjust.
P3: And also.
P3: You want to be able to compare.
P3: Like, for example, we don't know, is it.
P3: sulfur dioxide.
P3: In the.
P3: Sixth, month prior to the flare or is it the sulfur dioxide average over the last 654 months prior to flare so it will be helpful to have like loads of different options to compare.
P3: And ultimately yeah compare like point zero is the date.
P3: relapse or remission and what does the standardized variable look like prior to that dates.
P3: Because we're not called with my uvb analysis we imagine that the uvb was going to be much higher in remission been a relapse So if I was looking at that visually.
P3: I might have it relapse graph down here.
P3: On a readmission appear, or it could be on the same graph in different colors and you know you could be here for one stage of setup here for the other, but you know it has to be centered at zero for the event.
P3: Have I performed well yeah.
MODERATOR: i'm gonna stop the recording.
Okay.